Well,
the Cabildo de Gran Canaria scholarships,
if you don't have them,
if you have any questions on how to look for them,
is very simple,
enter the website of the Ministry of Education,
then to the scholarship and help section,
and there are those of the Ministry,
those of Cabildo,
those of the government.
Everything you want is on that page,
in that section for you.
1 super easy to search
eh.
Now the ones we have
active are all those of the town council of Gran Canaria,
which are those of scholarships
studies,
therefore mandatory,
which end now on March 13,
eh.
Mobility scholarships
but those are until October 31,
in other words,
we have time.
And and the help of linguistic immersion,
which is that of the ministry,
that this one is for the whole of Spain,
We also have it only until March 21.
Okay,
then we have the others
scholarships that I gave you in the previous section
and but that end up
in June.
So there is still time
and there is also the call for
architecture students.
Okay,
but keep in mind that it's 1 hour.